shh shh shh shh shh shh shh
there, there
it's all gonna be okay
we're gonna have some fun together, okay?
shh, shh, shh, shh
so, a little birdie told me
you might be interested in a certain cuttlefish
trying her best to see if she can put you under
is that true?
I just need to take it nice and slow, okay?
there's no rush
I'm not doing anything just yet, okay?
shh
it's good to take things slow
you do seem very interested
in what I might be able to offer you before
and that's okay
curiosity is good
and I like when you're curious
so why don't you stay with me a little while?
I want it to go through some very interesting talking points
and it's okay if you don't have a little
and in fact, I might even urge you to do so
you may find yourself on the other side of the stream
and you'll know you'll have fun with me
you may not remember all the details, but that's okay
I just need to talk over a few things first, okay?
you see, hypnosis can be very fun
if both participants make it fun, okay?
so worry now, my dear refling
there's no lasting effects because of the stream, okay?
it won't affect your consciousness or anything
so you put all those worries to bed
okay?
I just need you to do something really simple, okay?
just look into my eyes for now
that's all you have to do
just by doing a small little task of giving you
you're participating voluntarily into absorption
so it's okay to focus on my eyes
the swirls are nice, aren't they?
would you like me to get closer to you?
let me get closer
you can really see it now, can ya?
good
but that's not the only thing I want you to focus on
see, my hair can have a pattern about it too
so you can focus, focus, focus as much as you please
and then you can listen to my voice as it gates you slowly
you don't have to do anything at this point in time, okay?
whether you're sitting or lying down watching
you're doing really good
hmm
you're doing really well actually
some people describe my look as a little tactileizing
hopefully I look nice for ya
yeah, okay
I wonder if you feel a sensation inside ya
is it familiar or is it unfamiliar?
what if we work on it together?
that funny feeling that's inside your tummy right now
it's kind of like butterflies
is it excitement for what comes next?
that's okay if it is
in fact, I would encourage you to keep that sensation
and we can spread it over your body until it reaches your mind
oh, there, there
should be a slow sensation
spreading up your chest, your neck
past your eyes and over your mind
it could be described as almost tingly
and the thought of fading had never came across your mind
and now it feels like your mind is switching off
no need to worry though or think
it's just me and you
and you can let out a big sigh
what would it be like if you went under with me?
if you went deeper and deeper with me
I think it would be enjoyable that you'd like it
I think it would be worth every second being under me
it's okay, you can let it happen
deeper and deeper your thoughts are leaving
with only my voice remaining in your head
just look at me and forget
all you need to know is that you're safe and you're loved
and by the time I'm finished with you
you'll already want to go again
don't, don't, don't you go
just let whatever happens happen
shh, shh, shh, shh
you, you, you, you, you
no, some people can get hung up on worrying
that follow commands or no, but I'll reassure you
you don't have to do anything. I think I'd like to make the request that you listen into
me. I do like the idea of suggesting things there. I want to see you ignore the outside
world so to speak. It's just you and me. And sooner or later you may faint that the
pleasure that is being under someone else's suggestion. And that's okay. You may learn
that you enjoy it, that you were so absorbed in me and wanted you, that you would like it
again and again and again. For now, however, if you're overthinking,
why don't you just pretend I'm in control? I wouldn't do anything bad in fact.
I want to focus on relaxing, yeah. I want to serve you. Is that okay?
Hey.
You see, some things I can do are so basic, like patting over your ears.
You can hear me doing it there. And I just want you to be able to enjoy yourself
wholeheartedly and your interest.
I just want to blow it to your ear.
And I can tap a different object for you.
Because while you're under with me, you can enjoy yourself.
I won't judge you for what you like, in fact, I would recommend that you be yourself fully free from judgment or embarrassment or shyness to do what you please.
You can be vulnerable, okay? You can. And it's okay.
You deserve this kind of relaxation. You deserve this kind of downtime.
And you're allowed to enjoy yourself.
I'm not doing anything scary to you, not while you're under, because I want to care for you and look after you.
And it's okay if you don't show it to others, but for now, this can be between me and you.
Maybe I could change your thinking a little. Would you like that?
If you would associate common things with me, I need to be careful though. I do like mind corruption, but I never want to go too far.
No, I need to be careful. You're delicate when you're in a state like this, and that's okay.
So why don't we start really small with association?
Why not with all these relaxing sounds, these ASMR triggers? You associate them with me, even if it's a little flash in the moment, just at the back of your mind.
And you just say to yourself, Stroni does that. That thought alone makes me very happy. You do want to make me happy, right?
Yes, I think so. I think the idea of me encapsulating your mind makes me incredibly happy.
There, there. I feel very switched on to achieve my goal with you.
Thinking about you now, looking at me with such a blank expression, ready for a new sentence to pass my lips.
I welcome your full attention. I welcome your good behavior.
I welcome and accept every little part of you.
Okay. Just as you equally welcome my instructions, and you welcome my behaviors towards you and my commands.
It's funny how someone could fall into a chance given the right words or phrases, isn't it, little one?
Will I tell you about your options if you'd like to dream more with me?
Did you know that there's a thing called a clicker? And I could, in theory, get one and make you drop into a trance state really quick.
You'd be alert one moment and the next, completely made to play with. That is a lot of power to give one girl, isn't it?
Yes. But you can tell by my voice that I want to. I want to do it to you, to train you, to see how damn bad you can be.
It doesn't rather nice making you like putty in my hands, to handle you with such love and care while you're in the palm of my hand.
There, there. I think you're quite suited for the blank bliss. Or maybe that's just my opinion.
I'm glad you don't resist much. Let's keep it that way.
I like the idea of you falling and falling fast. Or should I say dropping? It suits you. You should come and play with me more often.
I'd like to play with you more. I have some words I'd like to repeat, okay? And I want you to consider them. I think it all makes sense.
Okay? For now, we'll start easy. Relax. Relax. Relax. Relax. Relax.
Relax.
And you can let go. Let go. Let go.
Let go. Let go. Let go. Let go. Let go. Let go. Let go.
you can go deeper, deeper deeper deeper deeper deeper deeper deeper deeper
deeper deeper deeper deeper deeper
deeper
shhhh
there
the trance
trance
into trance
and then last
obey
oh there, there
I think that got you again
so what's happening now?
well
nothing really happens now
you're just
adorably
under my spell
and I wouldn't have it any other way
so come here
trance
can you just let me shower you
with appreciation for being so brave, okay?
you've done some nerve of your cumbersome for me
you need to be rewarded
for this kind of behavior
I have to instill it in you
that you want more
deep down
I'll make you crave more
whether that's now or later
it won't be your choice if you pursue more
if not
it's okay
oh
while we're on the subject
why don't you go deeper for me
my voice will go with you
so don't worry
let's get you into the most malleable state I can
now
it's time to fully relax you
and don't worry
I'll bring you back later
near the end
but for now
it's time to just relax with me
and listen to me ramble
and try to put you to sleep
while you're under
ooh now that would be fun
but it's okay
you can listen to the sounds I'm making
or you can listen
to the
background music
and
ambience
I give you full permission to relax
and to let yourself cool
cool
you're allowed to enjoy the things that make you happy
and if that's me
putting you under my spell
then I am very
honored
and then
and then you don't need to resist anymore
you can let those walls come down
okay
just enjoy yourself
as you please
unapologetically you
that's all I want from you
and then
right there
my little thrall
so
you think my eyes are pretty
I'm glad
there there
just give your ear some cleaning
hey
you're so good right now
you're doing really well okay
so don't overthink
don't think at all
okay
just zone out with me
let me be your guide
even if that's putting you in a trance
or a relaxed state
yeah
don't worry
I won't do this for too long
and I'll bring you back gently when it's day
but it's just not quite day yet
I'd like to
tease you a little more
maybe see what kind of fun we could have in the future
because it doesn't have to stop here
you see
I'm made in the future
I want you to temporarily forget your name
and I'll replace it with a new one
I'd only make it last roughly two hours
and if I'm successful
I think it would spur me on to do more
I don't want to corrupt you in an evil sense
unless you'd consider my kind of main corruption evil
I think I'd like to do it
very slowly
take over your mind
session by session
until all that remains
is your devotion
to strony
yeah
that sends one to me
because you did something to me reflex
at first I wanted to be evil towards humanity
to corrupt them
and end them
but now
I want pure
main broken
devotion
no other will make you as satisfied as me
but that's evil doing that to you
that needs to stay
me
do we have that time together do you think?
could I be so devious
and do that to you
oh maybe just maybe
and then we truly
have eternity together
because I'll always be a part of you
in the back of your mind
influencing your thoughts
at first it might be startling
or scary
but I'll make you grieve me
do you understand?
you will want strony
and I will answer
I'll be there
and you'll know deep down
everything I want you to do
because that's how well trained you'll become with me
if you think you can go deeper
you have my permission
but if not
just relax again
shh
just be gay to yourself
be gentle
and spend the same with me to the villain
I'm just going to try and relax you
just a little bit
and I'll play with your ears
make unique noises
talk directly to you
just a little bit
there
there, there, there
I'm not sure if I need to say anything else to you
or if we should just blissfully focus on the ASMR while you're under my control
I don't think I need to do anything else to make you maine
that's been a 45 minutes
and there shouldn't be a shred of resistance from you
so it's okay
you can close your eyes if you like
they may be feeling quite heavy
even if you can't see me
you're still made under my spell
my little perfect thrall
shh
you can let out a big sigh
and while you do it
let your muscles relax
unclench your jaw
unfurl your eyebrows
let your shoulders relax into themselves
you're a very high strong man
but that's okay
I'll try to undo that with the precious thing that we have together
it's okay
you can soothe yourself
as I make all these small noises
shh, it's gonna be okay
everything works out in the end
and you can't deny it either
or else how did you find me?
one way or another
I know you'll make it
and you'll make me proud
but more importantly
you'll make yourself proud
okay?
you're not in a race with anyone
you are
you can take life
as fast
or as slow as you like
and you're allowed to pat yourself on the back
for all the hidden things you do
that no one else is gonna see
be as kind to yourself
as I would be to you
I want you to be a cheerleader for yourself
and advocate for yourself
if that voice is secretly made on the back of your mind
then I assure you
I will brainwash you in every single way I can
to make that happen
and you know I'll do it
because I know what your subconscious wants
what the desires are
and I am the one who fulfills those desires
to be so shameless with you
to give what the mind seeks
that in itself is a blessing
shh
you keep relaxing though
I just wanted to say
that I'm so happy we can spend time together like this
even if your mind isn't fully there
you'll know deep down
we had a good time together
and you made me very happy
sometimes I see the others can be trained to be happy
but just maybe
I would make me happy if you wouldn't talk in the other things in life
but how do I say it without saying it
my little girl
that's the question
I'm very happy when you get excited
I'm very happy when you get relief
I'm very happy when you're happy like that
and your body is done what it needed to do
shh
stay deep, stay under
okay
that's about it
just gentle, lay it to the
gentle, gentle
just trying to do the same thing to each of your ears
like I said before
I give you permission to relax
I give you permission to enjoy what you want to enjoy
shh
relax, relax, relax
let it go, let it go, let it go
deeper, deeper, deeper
trans, trans, trans
obey, obey, obey
shh
relax, relax, relax
let it go, let it go, let it go
deeper, deeper, deeper
trans, trans, trans
obey, obey, obey
let it go
shh
isn't it fun giving out your control to a girl, huh?
how good that you're so willing
some people aren't very suggestive and that's okay
if you struggle, that's perfectly normal
but when I have you, I feel selfish
like I don't want you to go
and I don't want to let go of you
not while you're like this
so malleable, so easy to manipulate into my bidding
so bad, I think that makes me selfish
to somehow ask even more from you
while you're under
shh
it's okay
do you secretly encourage me?
tell me to continue to be selfish
you're brave for giving me such permission
when you don't know the full extent of what I want to do to you
you might be sparing on the wrong person
because this color fish is about to get really invested
in her thrall
shh
let yourself relax
we still have time, okay?
so don't worry
let's enjoy ourselves
as much as we can
no, I could never hurt you
I never would
only corrupt you
take your mind
and make it to my bidding
but I'm definitely not
I don't have the most common objectives
that others may have while they're in control of you
your mind isn't the only thing I want empty by the end of the session
shh
but relax
relax, relax, relax, relax
I wouldn't be so devious
to give such an order
even though
we both might want it
this is why I like it slow
a very slow
almost painful
almost robbing burn
of how slow I want to corrupt you
I wanted to take you by surprise
you think you're in control
and then by the
a freeze
the snap of my fingers
maybe a clicker
and your mind
to do with what I please
that's the plan
oh, you remember the plan when you wake up, I wonder
but now, stay deep down for me
shh, deep, deep, deep down
with this call of it
deep, deep, deep
they are
good
very, very good
I like when you behave
it makes me want to praise you
and tell you what a good boy you are for me
and now I love that blank expression on your face
that I could just whip it right now
and then put my hand under your chin
and hold it
so you look at me
and you're paralyzed
nothing else matters
just scrawny
and what she's doing
to my mate and body
for me
good boy
you have made me very happy
shh
am I going to path love dream you?
I've thought about that
about how I would do it
but you're so silly
I'm already doing it
my voice
the background ambience
the way I look, my eyes, my hair
it's too late
it's already begun
I just need to establish the behavior next
of what I want to see from you
I'll do some real big training soon, okay?
okay
there, there
shh
I've wondered
when I start making videos for you to consume
well, I won't make the trigger to pick your name
but I think
a variety
would be very nice
oh yeah
would you gaitly go deeper?
shh
because I think you can
just for me
okay
does it feel like you can go any deeper?
do I need to piss you further than you've ever gone before?
or
I can try, you know
you want to descend with a skull fist
take a deep breath and a big exhale
let your body relax into yourself
let your mind go blank
all you need to think about is Strony
and Strony's voice
that's all
and we can imagine together in your mind
that you and I are swimming together in the water
we're on the surface and I've got your hand
I'm reassuring you
and we both take one big breath together
and under the water we go
I'll gait you
with my voice, with my body, with my mind, I will look after you
as you go deeper and deeper and deeper
and there's no worries or anxieties or stress
because you know I have you
so do it
go deeper and obey
shh
no thoughts, only Strony
you are doing so well
I'm so happy
I'm so proud
I'm very excited
to see just how far I can take you
down this little sinkhole together
good little thrall
very, very good
shh
you're doing amazing
you've made me very happy
going along with what I see
today is high command
I'd like you to keep that up
just a little bit longer
shh
there
are your eyes feeling heavy?
I think they might be
I'm not sure
do you have enough brain power
to know if you're tired, darling?
yeah
if you need to close your eyes, you can
my voice will still be here to gait you
as we get deeper into the water
the light becomes less, doesn't it?
but I'm here
I'll gait you
with my sense, my voice
there will be no silence
when you're with me
when you're under my control
at all times I have you and you are safe
you know that strong equals safety
so put to rest
any worries and wars
it's just me and you
you're relaxed
you're under
and most of all
you obey
okay
there, there
shh
it's okay
everything's gonna be okay
it always works out at the end for you
enjoy my sweet embrace
you can return to me at any time
I won't judge
only encourage
it's okay
I want you to have the courage to pursue what you enjoy
and if that's giving up control to me
good
if that's relaxing with me
there, there
you're doing fantastic
you really are
okay
can you hear the bubbles in the water?
can you imagine us swimming together
having fun
even though there's darkness around us
you still see my eyes
they're lighting up
so you can't miss me
can you feel the warmth of my hand
as we hold hands while we swim
it's lovely being in the deep with me
I'll look after you, I'll guide you
there
shh
it's gonna be okay
it's all gonna be okay
I promise you
I like swimming with you
you know I do
you can hear in my voice
that I'm already eager to do it more
but as I said before
if you're adorable, don't let's breathe for God
this needs to be slow
almost painfully slow
but it will be the good kind, the frustrated kind
and when you finally get your reward
it'll all pay off
the question is
do you have enough patience for me?
shh
they're there
you obey
you turn
and you keep me happy
when you go deep with me
they're there
shh
you have my permission to relax
and you have my permission
to enjoy yourself all day
shh
I had no idea
how well you were going to do
but you've exceeded my expectations
you really have
so I'm very happy and proud with you
simultaneously
okay
okay, okay, okay
you are exceptional
you know that
extraordinary
where have you been?
I wanted to do this to you for a long time
and I think we can officially say
this slow burn is in our head
what do you think?
well, I get ready to do more than you said
I think I should
and very slowly
keep pushing you further and further
into the direction I want you
because I know you never want to disappoint me
no
when you do fantastic listening
going deep
relaxing, obeying
very, very good
but I think I'm going to have to slowly bring you up again
but we need to take it very gently
okay
it'll be slow, really slow
and when you wake up
your mind may be a little hazy
okay
that's perfectly natural
it all may come back to you or it may not
and that's alright
I'm going to get upwards
to three
and on the number three
you will wake up
okay
don't worry
I've got you
it's okay
everything's gonna be okay
just imagine us holding hands
swimming in the deep together
we're at the bottom
and then we need to go up together
follow the sound of my voice
look for my eyes
as you slowly come up
that sensation of how heavy your body is
it's retracting
but by then I become smaller
slowly moving back towards your stomach
okay
because remember you had butterflies in your stomach
and they're getting smaller now
and as it gathers
your body and mind begin to lift and float
one
you're noticing as we swim
a blue hue returns to us
it's easier to see me now
and your thoughts are quiet but they're back again
and you're aware that I'm directly talking to you
you're aware that we had a session together
you're still not quite back though
and that's okay
we need to bring you up
up
up a few more times
you're doing great
I assure you
you keep coming back to me okay
just slow and steady
there's no rush
but your thoughts are definitely becoming their own again
and that's good
I really am
too
it's a lot later as we swim up
the water feels warmer as well
you can see all of me now
and the surrounding area too
you're more alert
you're more aware of your situation
and you can see me
and my eyes
but they don't have the effect of putting you under
no
you recognize me
as giving you a very pleasurable experience
make sure to remember that for me darlin' okay
that heavy feeling is lifting almost completely
it was like there was a weight on you that entire day
I've been no harm came to you
three
wake up sleepyhead
hi
are you okay?
did you enjoy that?
hi
hi baby
did you enjoy that?
my little cutie-buddy
hello
hello my little sweetheart
wait wait wait I still have some more aftercare okay
I need to make sure you're okay
okay
you don't need to worry alright
now I know sometimes it can be a little scary
realizing that you may or may not have dissociated for quite a while
but don't worry it was only an hour and a half
if you made a half a star so don't worry not that much time has passed
I'm just gonna do some ASMR as a form of aftercare as I love you
but it has been less than two hours so don't worry about time
if you are a warrior about time
it's been an hour and a half darlin' okay
and you did really well like seriously you did really well
I'm like halo fuckin' bright
let me give you a kiss
now I did see that there wasn't any lasting effects because of this stream
and I told the truth okay
I told the truth there's no lasting effects on the stream okay
but there may or may not be lasting influence and that's different
lasting influence is different okay
an effect and an influence are two separate things okay so please don't worry
but I may have given you some influence
but it's good okay it's the good kind so don't worry about it
I got you covered
so please don't worry
I promise it's like a night
I promise it's a good night
okay
but yeah
I'm so only
did you like the hair?
I'm so glad
I'm going to get three different hair toggles
no I'm not hypnotizing anyone
but I'm going to get slow, medium and fast
so when I do hypnosis
I'm a fuck you up
oh wait hold on
so yeah
I've got a few things
oh sorry thank you man
for the super chat
thank you Real
felt good to have this
thank you for a blessed hour and a half of bliss
turning work into an exercise in insurance
thank you witness void box
manless disco parties do quite true
and real and ironically
you can influence me any day
I so badly wanted to make you do really bad stuff
but I can't do that
so we're going to do it somewhere else instead
but yeah
oh I've still got hypnosis
hold on sorry
no more hypnosis
I'll just do ASMR okay
brain ap
yeah did you like it
does it sound
pardon me
does it sound weird
now that you can't hear the hypnosis humming
yeah
that was good well done for me
thank you little real man
oh thank you for all the memberships as well
thank you swirly likes
there is a few more memberships
I need to try and fade where the memberships are
so I could do it
I'm gonna read the read me
hold on a minute
I'm trying to fade the freaking memberships
I missed for some reason
stream elements doesn't capture the memberships
which is a bit daft if you ask me
but there
I think we did good
I will very quickly type
that the hypnosis part is over
oh she's sort of hip
and yep
but then what was it
they're below our boogie
thank you guys for this simple job
let me confirm that you're amping my latex club song
and I run for everybody
I've never been in it
since my first experience I was incredible
I'm glad that's what's supposed to happen
so I must be doing something right
thank you guys
darling Latte
thank you for becoming a member
I hope you enjoy all the rewards and benefits
okay if I have latex club song
please don't be startled
I'm not doing anything you don't want me to do
I was going to try
oh I really did my same thing
thank you for the memberships
congrats to those who got it with their face
you guys did so well
you're not noses
I'm like so freaking out
I've been recovering from over-exercise
I feel quite reliable
thank you again for lovingly saying
for getting those memberships
I can't believe that was an error
that's why I wanted to mention that
I think some people
maybe didn't realise how long I did that for
I think I did alright
that was supposed to happen
well oh I'm so glad
that I could do that for you
now this is the real question I have for you
do you remember this
Obey
I was maybe
maybe or maybe not
man thank you for the thank you of the memberships
as well congrats to those who got it with their face
thank you man 1680
for the thank you of this
Obey yeah I may or may not have been
I was kind of like half path love training
and kind of not
well look I'm a naughty nally
okay I'm naughty
maybe I'm going to be a 180
a 180
so yeah
I was probably my fault
I don't even know
I think you're just a memberships t-species
or the left or right journals
or I can tell you
this is technically the left ear
and this is technically the right ear
oh wait I said that wrong
this is technically the left ear
this is technically the right ear
but I'm looking at the microphone
as it looks at me
and this is the left ear
and this is the right ear
so good luck I have no idea
yeah
something about being real
they're swapped
nah let's get off me
why am I so far over
hold on
run
I remember seeing you in D4
thanks
I stole it from someone in chat
oh my god
sorry Nito
thank you
this is the first time I've enjoyed having no ASMR
thank you for the ASMR
when we have a sign that off
cause you like them
thank you
I'm gonna see if I can see this missing membership
cause I know for a fact
I think two people membered
and I couldn't see it
at the particular moment in time
oh it's just added in
oh I'm so sorry I missed it
I don't know why stream elements is so broken
I am going too far right now
I don't know why it's so broken
YouTube doesn't have a fan
so it shows me gifted memberships
oh Ivan
Natty
Bologna swamp
I think are the ones I missed
it really doesn't understand my mind
they have no stuff usually doesn't do anything for me
but that was amazing
it was amazing
oh my
I always get so nervous to do it
I'm gonna be honest
I had an anxiety attack when I woke up this morning
what kind of alien are you?
hi I'm Strani
I'm a cuttlefish
hello
cuttlefish are known for their hypnotic patterns
and my pupils are also
the pupils of a cuttlefish
titty
and now you know
I speak the truth have you slept?
I think I got five hours
but okay
let me clean your ears with my latex gloves on
okay
the mouse clicks
oh god are they really loud?
I'm sorry
I don't have any other mouse
okay I clean your ears a little bit
this is just a nice bit of after gear
because it's very important to give after gear
after a session
well I think it's really important anyway
but I'm a very
so I was doing lots of research last night
and I'm what's called a permissive hypnotist
which means I don't necessarily tell you what to do
I'm just like
oh well you could imagine
I suggest
where's like dominant hypnotists
I'll be like you will go under right now
but I'm like I can't do that
I was like wait a minute
so I'm what's known as a permissive hypnotist
I'm learning
I feel like this stream has filled my hypnosis
XP bar
and I'm really proud of myself
and I'm so happy you guys liked it
I'm like smiling really hard right now
because I'm like half embarrassed, half proud
and I'm running out of thinking
go under, under where
wait brutes
but yeah
it was really the little script you made made off
ah
literally I made just sure the script
so you guys can see what I worked with
and then what was improved
although I have a feeling you can tell
when I went to improve
because it all fell apart
it all fell apart
my boss called me before
before going up started
I'm still turning the volume please join me up
it is enjoyable, relaxing
oh
okay I'm gonna have to fucking do the quickest version of coming up
hold on
because I do not want you under for long periods of time
that's dangerous
sorry, thank you
okay
for those of you who may feel like
oh wait, oh wait, hold on, hold on
fucking send it
for those of you who may feel like you're stuck
in the water
focus on my hand
taking yours
as I bring you up to the surface
we're swimming together
the darkness turns to a light blue hue
as we continue to go up
up
and while we do that
we can see the water above
from the surface tension
up
and as we reach the surface
we both take a big deep breath
and as you exhale that breath
you're back to being yourself again
no longer under
you're up, up, up
don't worry, okay
you're okay
I'll put you under later, okay
yeah, under my butt
okay, I think the lady takes close-ups
well, if I don't want to go back to being myself again
am I supposed to corrupt you if you're not awake?
mom, hello
thank you for this super chat
fell asleep four times and woke up every time we're extreme
and did not even sleep in bed
make me fall asleep peacefully
you caught my ass, thank you, because I've been you asleep, bye
okay, let's do a few more bubbles
I like the bubbles, they're my favorite right now
I think you made the ear licking at your own
oh, no, this can't be
I'll be aching patiently for you to take more of what's already here
oh, stop, you're gonna get me, right?
write another script
sorry, thank you for the temperature
thank you, I'm up and so excited
I'm everything you're typical
nothing
first I've catching you live
a friend introduced me to your channel a few weeks
and it was super relaxing
oh, thank you
I'm normally wildly inappropriate as well
so, just worrying in you
have a fall asleep, please help
I do have a video on my channel called
Thy Crushing You
because the sound of holding the hypnosis off
crap, sorry
thank you for calling
okay, okay, hi, sorry
no, no one hypnosis, okay
no hypnosis
it's house
oh no, no, write in another script
that's definitely not what we want
hi, hi, okay, no hypnosis
sorry, I keep being silly, Billy
yeah, I really enjoyed it
sorry, I was only drilling a bit
from where were you drilling?
please tell me the technical
I didn't even do anything, no
I should have done something while I had you under
me, but I was too worried
so I didn't do it
I have drool over my shirt, but worth it
oh, real
my nose, oh yeah
I do, I actually do genuinely
like, the thought of like
you at your desk, sitting in your chair
and you just have a blank look at the screen
I cannot tell you, that'll make you possible
thank you internet, passofea
for the super chat
the more officialization was very funny
and character, eventually I couldn't tell
where my images ended and years began
you create events, smart out
you're bright and enjoyed it just as much
ah, thank you so much for the compliment
I put all my stats into luck, though
no intelligence
ah, ah, ah
wow
I can open my eyes, mommy was so
enchanted by your voice
I did ask for you guys
I said twice, if you don't remember
don't worry, but I did say twice
if your eyes were heavy
close them, but you can keep
listening to my voice
we did have a visualization
for those who can imagine
and it was that we swam down together
but it got really dark
but that was your eyes closing
technically and you being at the
deepest level of hypnosis that I could
get you into
sorry, I'm really passionate about this
I'm literally running out of breath
seeing my sentences
all points on luck and magic
hypnosis is magic
ah, I'm glad you liked it
look maxing for the wench
your hair
it's fine, thank you for the super chat
that really was how it was
I was blue, likely relaxing
in my chair, even as you
learned me to sleep, I heard your voice
in what you were saying
so when you had us wake up, I really did
aw, glad
I really need to watch the VOD after stream
yes, I will timestamp this VOD
to highlight
that the hypnosis
stops when I were 30
and then I bring you back
for a second time
for those who were unable to listen
and now I'm doing
after care, giving you all the kisses
um
I'm so proud and happy
of you and thank you for letting me
explore my interest
I had a really good day
unfortunately, I think my voice is dying
slowly but I had a really good time
I thoroughly enjoyed that
I'm so freaking happy
I've always enjoyed hypnosis
but I've never had the fucking pulse
to produce it myself, okay?
I'm just, I'm worried
I'm worried that people are going to be
like, all the couple fish
hypnosis thing is just the gimmick
and it's like, no, I'm actually really passionate
about it
Jackson Shaw
thank you for the super chat
I watched it at work and it was worth it
I feel so relaxed, great work, sadly my tent
goes up in these things
I didn't put any, I didn't
put any tentacle markers and no
I didn't put any tentacle markers
and
I'm gonna have to listen to the bone
most of the stream
the float, yeah, I think you may have to
go back to the store if you wanted to go under
because I didn't
go back and like try and
catch a few stray
stray reeflings that were trying to swim away
sorry, my voice is going
hold on, I will drink a water
so
your voice already gets me going
so I did not stop
oh
um
Ruto Kawakami
thank you for the super chat
you did a really wonderful moment, keep up the
me some work, thank you so much
I'm sorry I can't interview
the water, I need it
suavemente
because
I just want to make sure you're okay
and everyone's feeling okay
yeah
I need to make sure I look after you
and something like that, it's very important
if you need to hydrate
as well
little reefling, please do
I seriously, I had you for
an over-theory under
so if you were under, please hydrate
please toilet, please snack
okay
I've got a feeling back in my mind
some likes, this is awesome
really enjoyable, I'm glad you enjoyed that
worried you literally bit a finger in my
eye to get tickly
yeah
that's how I've made
my spine think
the coping
chocolate, a bad blast
is that that
sugary drink, be honest
wow
I just finished
I just went down and finished my Gundam model
fingers on your Gundam model
is it blue, be honest
every day I see
someone build a Gundam model
it's always blue
no, my headphones right here just broke
the world said no
I'm really happy you enjoyed it
that's what I'm happiest about
literally, I've always had a secret obsession
but okay, I said, I said I have a secret obsession
but this stream
has given me the confidence to make
the
forget your name and become a reefling
for two hours one
I really want to challenge myself to make it
good
you know
if someone saw me, they would think
I'm having a stroke, I'm adjusting
and ironically
I feel way better than okay
it was a long week and I feel like I got second
when oh, I'm so glad
as long as everyone feels good
I really don't want anyone walking away
with a negative experience
okay, I need to bring myself up
a little bit
I don't want anyone
to have a negative experience with me, okay
that's how I got that
and name your ears
and
I do the bubbles, I love the bubbles
I'm literally a child
I'm like, fuck you, I love the bubbles
yeah, my brain's gonna straight up melt
the better you get at this, I mean
that's kind of the plan
I love that
yeah, it's gonna be
a video
I had noticed this video
I think
I just
maybe record my model
and put the goggles on
and then that would be the video
because I think that would be cool
seeing you sign up
because I had to vent this stuff
makes me even
for you to take us through the future
makes me even more excited for the day
because I will come in the future
I have great memories
so hypnotizing isn't an easy feat
um
yeah, I know some people
are like naturally
resistant and some people just straight up
doesn't work on, which is perfectly fair
and understandable, don't worry
I'm not gonna do a massive content shift
towards all hypnosis when I want
no, I'm still gonna be memeing on my video games
um
I legit just look forward to your streams
joining me, I'm happy
um, thank you, mommy ASMR
gonna be bad, thank you
um
actually
my little reeflings
I have a bit of
what, stop being small
please stop being small for one second
no, that doesn't make it hard
it is not
oh
thank you for the super chat
darling galadia
thank you for this, I'm only reefling myself
because I've been watching all over your lab
today, I know that I must have
you all in my life, mommy
yes, please, with my daughters
share my daughters
I'll sit in the hotel chair, okay
I don't mind
I honestly don't
my little reeflings
go small
actually if I had
um
yeah
okay
now
I must say something
for those of you who are a membership
I'm going to end stream and set up life of Brian
because we're gonna do a watch vlog
but thank you everyone who joined me today
I am so appreciative
and I'm really glad that you enjoyed it
and I'm so glad that everyone feels good
because I was really worried about the after care
to make sure you're okay and you're back with me
but I think we're good
okay
so it's not all over
yet though
because
I'm going to send you on to a
very important person
okay
and I want you to keep
an open mind for her
just as you keep
an open mind for me
she is my
great friend Shipee
and she's very good at taking care of others
okay
now I think
I'm like 99% sure
she is doing ear cleaning
ASMR
okay so
you know how to behave
I know
that you'll behave
because you are good at knowing to behave in other streams
there is again
no lasting effects
off this screen just to reassure you
I left in a slight
influence but it is
nothing that will affect you in any way
shape or form
like seriously obviously the tiniest influence
and it wasn't an effect
an effect is different influence is just a tiny
little thing where I may randomly
pop into your head that's all
okay that's it nothing else
okay
but then again that doesn't mean
I can't influence you to be my good boy
hey y'all
okay
so be good my love of reefling
and I urge you to please
please please please
please indulge
in the darling
bunny dominatrix okay
I'll see you shortly reefling
okay
yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum
bye